now if I know Batman he's gonna have a  love interest yeah I also happen to know  more I carry yep is there that what I  think I can't really I don't want to  spoiler alert what goes on but let me  just say there's some pretty funny some  funny stuff yeah there's some funny kind  of love interest up that happens yeah  really yeah and you've always kind of  had a crush on mariah is that true me as  a person as an individual isn't it not  as a group as a group uh I don't know if  I would say that I've always had a crush  I mean I you know she's at such a talent  yeah you know so I've always been you  get serenade you so to speak I'd love  I'd love to see her try I would I'm  religion that's why I know you're  invited if it happens during but it I  would enjoy that as